hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my non-spoilery Wonder Woman
review also be sure to rank this with
the other DC EU movie so far there
hasn't been that many but there been a
couple there were so many expectations
going into this movie that I feel like
even if it had come close I would have
been happy like you know as long as it's
an enjoyable experience find good movie
great money well spent but this goes so
far above and beyond I don't want to say
that it blows other DC EU movies away 1
because we only have Batman V Superman
and Man of Steel to compare it to and
it's a very different character so I
really try to evaluate it more in the
context of who the Wonder Woman
character is and how close that gets to
comic book Wonder Woman in where she
fits into this puzzle of the Justice
League that being said I do rank the
films you know like the massive three
films they've done so far at the end of
the video but there is a new round of
the giveaway it's for IMAX give
certificates for the movie all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber or
leave a comment on this video and that's
actually a nice segue to just talk about
the cinematography first if you do have
the opportunity to see it in IMAX it
shot on film they do use a lot of green
screen for like the really big action
set-pieces
but there's this amazing color palette
that they show off that you haven't seen
before in DC movies Man of Steel is now
sort of the middle ground in terms of
beautiful looking films in the DC EU
now there's beautiful films and
beautiful looking film so I'm mostly
just talking about the cinematography
the way they shot and sort of like to
eat those that they were going with
looks a little bit Superman from
Christopher Reeve Superman mixed with
Batman Begins so you get a lot of the
realism of Batman Begins but you're
painting with a much brighter color
palette like the classic Superman films
did in the funny thing is - a lot of
people are saying that patty Jenkins
should do the next Superman film but
they've actually already started ramping
up on the next Wonder Woman film they
probably won't make any announcements
about that for a while but after you see
the movie you'll understand why they're
so excited about doing another one just
because she's so unique in the DC EU and
they have so many opportunities because
she's so long-lived
but overall the narrative is pretty
simple if you've ever read the Wonder
Woman origin story then you're going to
understand 99% of what's going on during
the movie it's pretty straight up it's
not meant to be over complicated they do
invoke a lot of the bigger ideas and the
DC EU like gods and brilliant
interesting ways so that's a bit of a
departure from the comics but otherwise
it's pretty much a straight-up telling
of her origin story from the different
errors in the comics they try to mix and
match things there are a couple of the
sillier things that they don't get to I
don't want to give away spoilers yet but
everybody's asking big questions about
are they going to put this in the movie
are they going to put that thing in the
movie what about stuff from the TV show
there's a lot of winking at things like
that but you have to remember this is
set during World War one so a lot of the
humor flows from Diana's interactions
with the other characters with Steve
Trevor
who's just trying to teach her about
modern society she's never met a man
before she walks around everywhere with
her sword and shield she wants to be a
warrior so badly
the only real point that the movie drags
on a little bit is during some of the
villain monologuing there is a little
bit of classic villain monologuing like
you have to have in some films like this
there's a certain amount of exposition
you have to get across why the big
villain is doing the thing that they're
trying to do there's a little bit of
that towards the end but the action is
so great that usually you're not paying
attention to stuff like that you're just
so swept up in it you look at shots like
this it just gets so crazy it was so
great to see them incorporate so many of
her abilities from the comics that was a
big question when Batman V Superman
rolls around you saw her take on
doomsday and you saw that she's super
fast she's very strong and she wields
the god-killer sword which can pierce
doomsday skin which means that she could
also probably take on Superman at least
for a little while but that was about
all we've seen her do there are other
special powers that she has they show
the full gamut during this movie you'll
be blown away by some of them the lasso
of truth has been in all the trailers so
obviously that's her main weapon they
find really funny and really badass ways
to use that to gal gadot does this
really good job of showing Diana as
being this very eager very aspirational
character it's kind of like this deer
caught in the headlights in the way that
Clark Kent Superman does not because he
was raised by humans Yuri watched those
scenes during Man of Steel when Jonathan
Kent is telling Clark about how he has
to hide his abilities because people are
afraid of you so he grew up with a lot
of that baggage and his influences the
way he interacts with other people but
Wonder Woman doesn't have any of that
she just grew up hearing these grand
tales of the Amazons
history of their people he's crazy Wars
watching all these artifacts who gets to
wield that sword only the most worthy
will I be worthy someday so there's a
sense of excitement from her taking her
destiny on that you didn't see in the
Man of Steel film Superman embraced his
destiny but Wonder Woman is like running
at it headfirst with her shield just
soaking all these bullets and yet she's
powerful but she's not as powerful as
Superman it was really exciting to see a
character like her be so excited about
being Wonder Woman you know so many
superheroes are really bummed out about
their powers they feel like it's a
burden they have this Duty that they
have to perform Wonder Woman is
genuinely pumped up about being Wonder
Woman in making the world a better place
and you know fundamentally that's what
the movie is all about is a very simple
idea there is war let's try and make
peace on both sides so even though it is
so much fun to watch the action
sequences she does not revel in hurting
other people but have you seen the
trailers you've seen Batman vs Superman
you know a little bit about her fighting
style they dedicated a giant portion of
the film to training montage there was a
lot of fun that will make you feel when
you rewatch Batman V Superman like she
was holding back against doomsday she
didn't really get to nuts during that
she gets way nuts during Wonder Woman
so he goes way beyond the acrobatic
stuff you've seen in some of the
trailers there been a couple shots of
her going off the rails but they take
her to the limit in this movie the
supporting cast was great the Amazons
are badass you've probably seen the
footage with Robin Wright Penn Hippolyta
was great Chris Pine was a really solid
pick for them too he's the world-weary
cynic that's a good counterbalance for
Wonder Woman's optimism and then Eddie
candy is just so much fun I loved her
character I can't talk too much about
Ares character without getting into
spoilers so I will do more Wonder Woman
Easter egg videos later where I'll talk
more about him in depth and when I say
they take her to the limit during her
big bite scenes he's a big part of that
so it paid off big time I was very happy
with the way they did Ares there were
just a couple minor complaints I had
about some of the CG like I said some of
the big monologuing scenes dragged on a
little bit but otherwise the tone the
cinematography the actors the
performance and patty Jenkins the
director were all fantastic overall
gives the movie like an eight eight
point
five out of ten solid B plus a minus is
a really high watermark for the DC EU
but obviously a lot of the tone the way
it looks is very specific to Wonder
Woman's character so that doesn't mean
that they're all going to start making
the DC movies look like the Wonder Woman
movie it's all about making a Batman
movie that feels like a Batman movie
he's not going to be walking around
sunshine rainbows happy all the time
that's just not the way the Batman
character works but after this I do
agree that patty Jenkins should get a
swipe at the next Man of Steel movie
whenever they end up making that now
like I said they have talked about doing
another Wonder Woman movie that's said
in the past that could change they
haven't made any official comments about
that but once you guys do have a chance
to see the movie let me know what you
think of it in the comments below I say
you know ranking the movies now say
Wonder Woman is my new favorite Man of
Steel second Batman V Superman third but
that's not to say that I don't like
those other movies I just feel like
Wonder Woman did a much better job with
the characters than the other films did
with the characters in those films but
you have to remember because there's
this huge arc that's going on with
Justice League so I'll reevaluate this
at the end of the year when we start
talking about that movie so plenty more
Wonder Woman coming later this week
leave all your requests for bonus videos
in the comments below while you wait for
everything you can click here for brand
new flash and you can click here for my
timeline explainer for the DC EU thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you